this [ __ ] stupid huh huh huh dummy
this is how hard it is to get in here
you know that right welcome to the big
leagues bro what do I do
are you doing out the corner of your
house take your glass I hear man
go ahead and squeak by glasses 70-inch
TV Gabriel take your glasses off right
now now the [ __ ] you guys started how
long's it been going to hey we were just
talking and what I'll raise your voice
Jackson okay home Jackson I'm here man
out you know he's so hip he's got a rope
now do you approve of the Rope for a
belt did I do a Chris yeah what kind of
jeans are those bro call her jeans are
guys guys we had the same coat on last
night you know how much it's costing I
don't know I don't know you know why
[Music]
[Music]
dude just like my social studies time
looking man hey you [ __ ] what is that
what is that yeah dude what the [ __ ] bro
what are you doing man what are you
doing taking why you dressed so [ __ ]
regular because I'm a [ __ ] regular
man no it's not rating you know I'm not
some Wallflower all right I'm not some
decorating for these [ __ ] sunglasses
on dude take them off your bird take my
wall if I won't I won't hey happy bird
take them off right now don't call me
happy you're a happy bird take em off
right now Harry dude what are you guys
talking about before I even got here ah
believe some [ __ ] like some matter oh
that doesn't matter it doesn't matter
cuz the show [ __ ] started right now
dude the show started
oh my god I was walkin around like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude you know how hard
and annoying it is to get to [ __ ]
three it goes security bro no it's not
security madam it looks like
we scramble all the we scramble all the
name the words the numbers people can't
find us some people can't find the right
words a number named named number hey
sweetie
scrambled brains how about a homeboy
less at the Comedy Store
oh yeah this guy comes up then he's
gonna kill us
the word is bird I've seen in a long
time
yeah we're birds Hank it's hard to make
me uncomfortable yeah I know
and I felt unsafe and I felt like the
biggest puss killer is there security
around here she was unsettling yeah
really
why--i I you just kept following us all
right he was like like just like you
part of the crew like yeah and then goes
come on bro you use like I know he's
like I wrote kamikaze I said what the
the Eminem album and he said yeah and I
said Eminem wrote that album man I said
I gotta go and then he followed us
whatever he's at my house now but he
wouldn't leave me alone so I just kept I
just brought him the whole I just
brought what did you do with him and
where did he sleep he's chilling he's in
the guest room it's been cool actually
oh cool yeah I don't know if thanks
you're a good guy ah so you you what did
you do what what have you done today
woke up drove over here took [ __ ]
three hours [ __ ] what you guys are [ __ ]
where you guys are and then also when
you get here you're not here yet
let me just tell you [ __ ] everyone
here who's listening okay it's you go up
to the [ __ ] floor that it's on and
then the the first number is 3,000 so
already pissed okay because the first
number should be one dude okay take it
easy and we all know that all right cuz
first is one right and then you get here
and it's that you look and it's like
3085 and you're like and you walk to
another area like you turn the corner
and then it's a 3022
it's all are like what the [ __ ] it's all
that's like why have you ever been
honorable fine this right yeah but you
need me have you been the guest have you
ever been - what's a lot the Fox lot
it's the same thing yeah those all those
buildings is there's building one and
then building 92 right next to ya what
[ __ ] I don't know man same guy and I'm
gonna tell you something don't ever
compare
self - a [ __ ] legit Network like Fox
when you go to the when you go to the
hair cut place yeah do you say give me
the Jimmy Neutron do you say that word
for word what do you say I want this and
then show them a picture of the back of
a ducks water on my front is that what
you do dude hey look [ __ ] Ace Ventura
son okay I do peel it up and I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get up I'm gonna get it
dude why is it doing that today I don't
like it I tried and trim it down
yesterday and now I'm feeling a little
self don't you touch it so I do face it
why do you like this I start raining
your hair why do you do like this like
you're felling like you're picking up
because you're watching it's it's fine
dude it's it's fine don't piss me off
okay man you seemed really on edge today
I'm good you know who I saw yesterday at
the TCA the ABC Television Critics
Association gathering was it guy to be
along person bill D'Elia yeah yup
what is he doing hanging out it was
producing some ABC she'll show is he
doing
you know what he said to me which was so
cool he's doing blackish no well no he's
no but I saw one of my favorite people
Laurence Fishburne talked to him what do
you say I saw your boy oh I know what he
said he said oh I'm so busy another
seventy year old I'm so happy to see
another 70 year old Chris cuz when I set
that picture yeah it was a video you
have you of cool to seven-year-olds
talking you're a [ __ ] well you
guys they said to me guys I'm so happy I
love your show and it's you're so
talented this is his dad they feel yep
and he goes and he goes and he goes he
looked at me he put his hands on my
shoulders and he goes and he got
teary-eyed and he goes you're the son I
never had no any because you're the
reason why Chris yes we said Chris Chris
barely
got by and you were such a huge
instrument in that facilitation diego's
you're the reason he is with you and I
said well I and he goes and he bites
your style and I want you to know
tonight you suppose him but you don't
and I said and I hugged them thank you I
know it was so cool did you know where I
can't wait to you know what I can't wait
why I can't wait till you make it
I can't wait to make it I can't wait to
you I'm can't wait to you you don't let
me out of an escrow I did that can't
wait til you make it
don't do that cuz I let you I let you
fly us all good man dude it's crazy that
my wallet is [ __ ] not
I usually it usually don't fold hey
Brenda the kind of snake that is on his
wallet there are thousands in there
that's a coral snake there I put [ __ ]
dude are theirs out are they coming out
with thousand-dollar bills I need that
it'd be nice I need that yeah I saw you
have this thing bags I'm in the dude
yeah yeah the Brinks trucks bro you're
in the yeah bro cuz I saw that instantly
got angry yeah well Bob about this
there's my new theme song dude some guy
made it dude I'm in the [ __ ] you know
what I'm in what the bag unit that's
where I'm in the bag you yeah hey let me
ask you this B do you know Marshalls
Marshall Mathers retweeted Julia I did
not know that why wouldn't that be mmm
yeah that would be dude you're good
that's weird that you didn't know that
cuz unsocial me didn't happen yes we did
you he retreated you yeah what did you
tweet alright no I did a video of me the
video that's rapping like Eminem and oh
you wrote how it was you have to but
that's not the video they're actually
cuz that's tweet just screenshot that's
good as Curtis yeah it's [ __ ] good
though did you
you didn't post it to Instagram I did I
posted a video yeah yeah yeah ooh the
dog my dog we're in the background oh I
see him just like what is dad doing he's
literally just like you saw this in your
garage yeah
I don't know I [ __ ] bored did you
film it yourself you can do this i'ma
just shut it up it was so dumb I should
not show Brian the reference yeah so
Brian oh is this the one where he goes
bad on Trump no no it's not that one's
in a park and everyone's like why are
you breathing so heavy but he was
breathing that's exactly and he posts
that he goes and Eminem post goes dude I
thought this was me he was about your
style I mean he's awfully high off his
ass
uh-uh no it no it's not that one um it's
it's called the it's called something
cipher no but it's called
it's like 11 minutes just right 11
minutes it's like 11 minute oh yeah
there we go there you go it's 11 minutes
just use it that one yeah it's gotta be
this is not that one no okay
Kanye released keep going down its it
why is 11 minutes not up it's probably
the first one this one is it 11 minutes
yeah alright that's the one but can you
imagine being a real battle rapper no no
no you ever seen when they get thro this
chase yeah and then I do punches the
other one does he like grills I'm so bad
shoutout to white rappers Frank can you
do that imagine Brian doing this now is
he now his facial hairs weird yes I
don't know I know dizzy maybe he just
hear brush maybe it's gray or something
anyways just four men every six right so
that's yeah how much of that has been
thought of how much of that is being
recalled how much of it you know what
you know what I don't think I honestly
don't think it matters
oh yeah that is so brave and I get
people are like he's rhyming everything
it's corny like it's the the thing to do
now is to just not give a [ __ ] and
barely rap and mumble is you know what I
mean
which is it's not as farm if you wrote
that is right yeah outline but he's
direct but here's the other thing you
like you know Watson
you asking me a question right try to
answer it sorry bro sorry man it's all
good but we made a mistake together
right right well yeah I guess all right
cool
cuz I was answering a question you
interrupted me so we made a mistake
together right yeah yeah all right so
okay cool
all right you know it's great to three
[ __ ] white guys how about rap yeah
yeah I'm talking about a white rapper by
the way also also you know when you're
on stage and you're you're doing like
crowd work but you've kind of done a
version of it before because you've done
40,000 shows it's like he knows what
rhymes already is a blooper he's he's
already rhymed a word with another word
and said a thing like this before so I
think it's like that okay I feel like
he's started as he gets older he looks
weird to me it's just a facial hair
there's some it looks like it was
artificially put on or something maybe
he's yeah Chris acting like he's friends
buddies now that we know more but is now
wow I mean each other I mean he wrote me
and I wrote back and it's all because we
don't I guess I lost his number why
don't you be a rapper you I bet you get
time to hang out with Hank Smith but I'm
Jeff Smith I'm a rapper oh yeah I forgot
yes you're a rapper yeah put up my
life's life said documentary you never
saw this life my life said documentary
right my life said documentary in
YouTube oh yeah YouTube yeah yeah yeah
Chris is a rapper man it was born on 10
min uh yeah it was there you go oh snap
oh [ __ ] when was this was this a while
ago it only has 47 thousand views cuz I
wasn't you know I should have done it
now
street lamps shoelaces over telephone
wires on a fire the wire I never saw
this is really good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is [ __ ] awesome
that's mr. green he's a legit producer
[Music]
dude this was this for years or years
not real cuz I cook all this [ __ ] in the
kitchen I'm only Braille cuz the [ __ ]
I'm spitting I'm only real cuz [ __ ]
question these streets of my religion my
nice attack you mentally
[Music]
was it weird to do it around those real
like rappers they know you're kind of
mocking it the the I had a meeting with
ti because I wanted to make like a
mockumentary about this but like do it
like I wanted to do it like how it was
like really like I wanted to make people
think like does crystally of really
think he's a rapper like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with him because to me that was
the only way like you could if you
really worked at rap well it's it's it's
silly you know but but but I wanted to
get like an actual good beat like I
didn't want it to be like Malibu's Most
Wanted like I wanted to be like yeah I
wanted it to be like borderline
borderline like bad but it's like but
there's effort in it yeah you know you
can see it is actually oh yeah it's well
done I came up with a whole storyline
look if you go to go to the Chang Smith
page if you just go to the upper left
one tim is his own page yeah so the I
had a whole story where I want to get
click on that so Chang Smith is from
prim Nevada where it's just like a rich
is like nobodies from there that's where
you stop you know to go to [ __ ] Las
Vegas and he works at Starbucks and he
was like really wanted to be a rapper so
he left to go to LA to become a rapper
you know and he had like a girl in prim
but he wanted to [ __ ] like go to he's
finally the the the album was before
that my life's a documentary and the de
Lyon laughs the documentary was the
first music video but the album is a
whole like go to shank is such a fine oh
like go to let's see hold on um good I
don't know just go to Lyon hey Fran Hesh
good oh my god go to Anne Heche on the
bottom left whatever happened to her
tonight I'll [ __ ] that party in the
[ __ ] that's how it goes was a fiasco
Smith bring up see uh but but mr. green
produced and he's like a legit producer
did like legit Pete yeah the beats are
awesome dude yeah so he came over it in
in in 2012 I mean this is a long time
ago yeah and he was in my apartment and
we were just [ __ ] laugh our asses off
Mick in these we didn't write any of it
we just [ __ ] will be be like okay what
can I say now none of it rhymes I mean
some of it rhymes you know I mean but
dude we were we were crying laughing
dude just taking the piss out of a rap
and and and and it was so funny cuz it's
like I mean it's he was like the because
he's a legit producer he's like he's
like he make he works with all these
[ __ ] guys but he's just and we were
just [ __ ] dying and then I was like I
didn't want to make it like I didn't
wanna put it on my YouTube I wanted him
to be his own thing which I suppose I
should own mine but this was before I
was in stuff so if I came up with it now
it would probably have [ __ ] a lot of
way to edit yeah yeah it's gonna go to
the chorus and do well rap yeah like
when you listen to Tupac or biggie or or
yeah go back go back a little bit I
can't remember go back go back go back
go a little bit more back yes okay
[Music]
[ __ ] everybody only girls so that's why
they call hit that name and hash him up
I do nothing funnier when white guys get
into like gangster rap like yep did you
ever see I think it's a Malibu's Most
Wanted [ __ ] hilarious over the top
yeah but do you ever see Vince Vaughn
when he didn't be cool no no yeah no I'd
sort of is he doing it seriously or
[ __ ] toys no he's he's playing a
character and he's like a rap manager
but he's you know he's kind of act like
Chris's and it's [ __ ] Vince Vaughn
it's in fun I'm capable easy come on
baby Weezy I don't know if but yeah
actually seen it it's great and the
rocks in it and the rocks I know it
security but he's gay the rock before he
was doing steroids dear Vince Vaughn is
so funny why are you doing that man he's
crazy man what's up you know I Love You
Man
he does a good job in this he wheezy
look at how great he's also like six
[ __ ] five five six digits it with
henna like a [ __ ] yeah he's
great dude he's a [ __ ] big boy I just
so yeah the rock looks way smaller there
so yeah so when the rock first got the
entertainment he kind of went my route
where he thought big was it like he was
in get roles so he got really skinny
self-conscious members it sounds like
water you doing you know I came in
Schindler's List - gonna be a meathead
for sure get big yeah names like oh
you're right career went yeah I know I
get it see big no-no but so yeah so he
was doing alright but not always big but
that's do you get that big without like
steroids I don't answer this question
you're not yeah I don't know that his
fans I have no [ __ ] idea I do
okay well that's done all the steroids
Christmas look and when he first started
on the left there in that's Hollywood
after you stop WWE still a big guy
obviously but well yeah in there yeah
sure like look at his shoulder yeah
usually they say when you can see traps
that are just bad developed yes I'm
going you've really the shoulder so much
you know but there's other are you
serious
but also are there other but no I just
have a question are you serious
but also is there I love doing that is
there um there's other stuff you can
take right like not like a steroid like
steroid hormone he's dope he's getting
to an age where he always 50 right oh
yeah he's very 50 yeah yeah very bra I'm
gonna get that I'll be 2003 rock yes
right now button right now I'm a combo
of 2003 and scroll up in the middle
right there in 1983 he's 11 there so
that's yeah I know
eleven-year-old that's right it's weird
that he's like seven have you ever seen
a schedule
yeah it's someone showed me his like
tooth out to 2030 he has like 74 feature
films he has to do dude oh so in the
u.s. that's not true so so what they do
is this has exaggerated over I know you
get signed
you get like so you'll be attached to
say 20 films so Sam Jackson those guys
they're attached to a shitload of films
but really they end up doing like The
Rock still here he does like 68 does
crazy amounts you know what I hated on
forever was Jumanji cuz I loved the
Robin Williams one and then finally I
was I'm good I was like you not [ __ ]
check it out dude it was awesome yeah
the rock is not ridiculous
the rock is awesome and and that that
Holt they did they figured it out like
he figured it out it was like when Jim
Carrey did like what was that majestic
movie and and just yeah
the we own the theater yeah and everyone
was like and then and then Jim Carrey
was like [ __ ] it all I'll do and then he
did like Bruce Almighty or whatever [ __ ]
that movie is just like okay people
that's what you you got it
it's it I don't want to say stay in your
lane because these guys can do it all
Jim cares a great actor and you know but
it's like yeah it's like great in Truman
Show yes yeah yeah but it's just like
when you figure out the thing yeah great
punch or club but like the thing you do
is the thing that's gonna make you a
[ __ ] star you know because the other
thing you do a lot of other people can
do that or where the thing what got you
to the dance was being keep you at the
dance but here's the thing
nobody can do nobody can do Ace Ventura
like a spike like Jim Carrey nobody
correct nobody out there so that's what
he does best and that's what he's gonna
owe mask is great let's list off all his
movies guys I know the mask was amazing
no seriously though nobody could [ __ ]
do that know what I know what I wanted
you is the real you know what my [ __ ]
it to remake the mask in a [ __ ] like
a serious way where it's like an a real
[ __ ] superhero movie and but dark ah
that will be awesome like almost like a
dark I know Brian to do that because it
with the promise you would do it and
then I go I'm interested in that girl
stop the presses
I don't know it's one other role do you
mind is in the new Joker movie I know
that's cool good thing you didn't do
that before you got the part man not the
Joker Riddler do serious role that's a
good [ __ ] job it's not dude hey and
the check your dude you said good job
that's what gay yeah you're like kind of
a kid come on look how Bryan looks how
cool
that's me coming back from craft
services yeah yeah that's cool at least
you don't have a farmer's tan oh my god
at least you don't have a [ __ ]
farmer's tan dude and that was that wig
bro yeah this is an expensive way yeah I
know [ __ ] that Chris how long's your
hair been long forever yeah do you have
a picture of you with short hair you
like a glamour shot [ __ ] dude why
does your hair looks like that right
there your face and hair right there
looks like you'd be on that sitcom wings
I know that the middle one then a
[ __ ] oh not rude I know the Joker
picture you're looking at hair change um
yeah
everybody thought it was real you're
here Keisha kept it dude I had a really
nosy answer that so so when I was on a
big movie set no they didn't know it's
so real because it's later rendezvous no
you know I'm saying but if you don't
know me you would you would never know
because it's lace front right and dudes
were like [ __ ] it was really
interesting because I I had an
experience where I was
people thought I was an extra right and
they were so rude to me yeah you like
[ __ ] yeah you're like wow man you know
you forget that I was like oh dude this
is I asked what they say you shouldn't
be here because you shouldn't be around
here you guys got to go over there you
gotta get over there you can't be over
here Wow and I will and I did say okay
because usually [ __ ] Phoenix
yeah well just being an actor you're
treated very differently than when
you're an extra sometimes not always
you're the same thing in every aspect
I'm sure like even then if I took my
heart same way my try at the NFL I
thought they'd roll out the red carpet
like skews yeah yeah we don't even know
your name yeah you don't have a locker
it happens
we ran over and over and over again like
I mean like comedy last night dude the
door guy was like hey man got to get out
of the hallway you're making noise and
said to me and people I was with and I
was like him and were fine
I I was in my buddies works at Wall
Street nobody works on Wall Street they
had a pack as they wanted it literally
like delivered downstairs to the next
building I said I'll do it yeah they go
no no cuz we gotta wait I go I'm going
down there what do you want to do it
because we just got to drop it off to
the doormat to the guy and just have him
sign for it I go give it to me I'll give
you [ __ ] I'm going down so I go down I'm
just a normal guy man no I go down and I
go he go I want to drop this off and
because I got a sign for it oh yeah and
I go I don't have a pen and the guy next
to me goes it's [ __ ] idiot doesn't
have a pen how do you [ __ ] deliver
[ __ ] you know I'm a paladin what a
[ __ ] idiot you punch his face you
know me yeah you know no you know me I
say tonight I see red yeah I will fight
you drop down on your knees yes I will
just come would you do I said I looked
and I go so I don't work here but you
can go [ __ ] eat a dick or something
like yeah yeah no this was in New York
City dude where was this in New York
City Oh what kind of a place it was a
building oh I took the package from one
Wall Street building to another I
remember I member bah bah bah ah [ __ ]
and then he threw a punch I slipped it
Ryan I ate a never
I can't marry exactly what happened I
broke all the river it's under this
right the left side the Brian and then
yup and then I killed his friend I know
I know I know I know he go don't play
with very bad can I take last night was
that one of the most embarrassing nights
I've had the Comedy Store because I
always I always like to fly under the
radar only can he see I noticed I kind
of dressed down at The Comedy Store I
ever dressed loud or orange shoes right
and I sneaked my car I put it on low so
I don't want thinking that dude like I
can't pull but still I don't have my
boss man and so I when I pull I mean I
bought a new rap tonight which is
ridiculous it's like a souped-up rat
over it's so they couldn't fit it in the
sudra but I I when I was I was driving
on my god when the [ __ ] a park I
started stressing out i text drew my Wat
Kenzie's like you'll be fine not a big
deal man like I'd [ __ ] it and I looked
at the [ __ ] billing I'm like who's on
there obviously Brian's me cool with it
Chrissy me cool Rogen loves cars and
then I saw Ron White I don't know Ron
right but the older comics I don't want
like ruffles yeah yeah yeah yeah I was
so stressed
really I would affect my performance I
watch it I guess I'd be great to get him
I talk to Ron he said he doesn't
anything to do with you let's get model
yeah no go to the video Brian post it
that's the monster really funny cuz he
couldn't get out
check out dude it was a nightmare and I
told the guy yo dude I'll give you $100
park it up there though I don't want it
down there yeah I can't meet ya I'm Lily
right here for at least don't why didn't
you just take the other car cuz I know
you want to provide it yeah yeah yeah I
wonder I got it it's been raised up you
know how it goes bro you got a truck
can't relate to us bro I thought I I
have a Jew I can do don't ever get that
[ __ ] twisted man okay I want I want
to be serious I know we have a [ __ ]
fun podcast here and it's a it's on the
comedy charts yeah dude I have a G Wagen
okay I don't I don't ever want you to
get that [ __ ] twisted and that's
[ __ ] serious dude yeah okay all right
yeah I don't know back to fun okay well
I'm not alright no need to be I don't
need to quantify what you drive oh oh
hey no no it's all good dude let's go
back to fun huh let's go back you know
you're talking to me the way I talked to
that door guy I'm saying haha are you
laughing in a good way or what's line
you see what happens is mmm blood starts
to boil yeah
blood starts to boil right starting to
see the bun I see it and I don't want to
make [ __ ] I don't want to make your
body look like your bank account which
is one low dance okay okay Brian full o
dance Cal don't these because I could do
my shows and people go
follow me yeah maybe people call me
sweet tart tart nasty do you know how
many come on go ahead and just say this
you're a sweet tart our paths may run
away hey lady gay out of a big gay al
what's that who you said he called me
hey al I told me okay oh I said old or
something and with wrinkles or something
I don't I forget but even at the show
when I read what I say and then my
friend he said that Barry go and then my
partner in crime Brian the kid count
walks in guys y'all big gals like 51
year old gay men they love this doesn't
have fans but you know when they turn
against you man and they are turning
against you or dense Brian this full oh
that's Cali good good
oh my god no shirt selling by the way
man Oh real well man cuz they're [ __ ]
fly dude they're fun they're funny [ __ ]
and they're fly dude leading how that's
like you got ya bro you're damn right
yeah okay they're bleeding bro yeah
whatever kind of [ __ ] bi is such a
dick you're such a that's what I do when
I [ __ ] go to the bank you want me to
sign that's what I do I don't give a
[ __ ] dude I don't give a [ __ ] you're the
most disrespectful man I'm respectful
cuz I'm being the way I wanna be dude
and I me true me is being respectful cuz
you get the true me you Welk and also
I'm [ __ ] I'm relaxed in front of you
man because we have a rapport we're good
dude if I'm uncomfortable I'm not being
the real me that's disrespectfully [ __ ]
bro right um I'm chillin I'm chillin
yeah and [ __ ] the guest of the year dude
I don't want I don't want to be the
guest we didn't bring I'm my own [ __ ]
you listen to congratulations if you
wanna [ __ ] dose of me dude you wanted
the posts come over to congratulations
dude hey listen I want to be a guest
that watches out making a Pakistan on
duty they [ __ ] I don't make are you
still working out like crazy yeah do it
alright you thought you don't post as
much yeah
come on the world but I do all I'm not
no I'm not dude your next looks don't
take this the wrong way what your neck
looks on Oh your eyes boy your neck
looks us unfortified I know yo let's say
you know bro I'm [ __ ] box judge
anything for your legs ever and we know
that I squat and that's okay I squat I
squat every [ __ ] 3-4 days not just
the bar do you squat because your legs I
can do 225 5 times probably not true
right I've worked very hard will you
have new knees and we know that your new
eyes well your your new knees have never
been used so I can see how you would
bare some way what are you talking about
I have a new knee we've never done
anything with your legs dude besides sit
and stand ups no no no no no I [ __ ]
and impose I like going to the gym I
work out very hard I sweat very hard and
I [ __ ] and I burned calories man do
an eighties workout you do lat
pull-downs and you don't do that bench
press on the and then you walk go home
oh you know what [ __ ] I met detect you
and give me some heat yeah uh that
company rogue for the salt bikes yeah
you trying to get one no I want I want
the treadmill that we ran out on it
though the curve one that's the skill
mill you want a would way there's seven
million there seven thousand dollars
there's seven million dollars it's just
seven million dollars but there's seven
I walked up one I was like oh that's too
expensive I can't smell a treadmill
might be able to help you with that
really oh no what are you doing hey hey
hey hey Brendan what are you doing a lot
of fighter and the kid do it and being
respectful don't do don't do that
now plane it let me see this video Joe I
got haven't seen it yet
I was stuck on a bar they had to move
all the cars oh my god
never fear you bring that again no I
never bring a pistol use that you what
is that noise what kind of my truck gone
wow I like that what horsepower is that
oh it's modded it's tuned up twin turbo
okay so you get off to LA wait say you
walked out of that shirt to afford yeah
you're gonna come off a lot about four
and fifty horsepower yeah then old big
brown comes around yeah there's not a
[ __ ] big Backstreet Boy yes I can
very similar so yeah but that's a same
but this this yeah but suppose they
clash a gene row you know what this is
for what
cuz I'm [ __ ] always getting in fights
and winning no no cuz I [ __ ] you know
I'm never been delete I know but it's
just the near no no because I take my
shirt off and that's when they usually
run away but when they don't my buddies
all scraped up but it is oh yeah last
fight I got it yeah thirty five minutes
ago oh my god Wow on the way here yeah
it's sucked I to pull over
guess who else got a street fight last
night you no no no my god yeah I like
the way you laugh hey job yeah it's in
the parking lot the gym
what happened talk on the phone you just
flips out some guy didn't turn on his
blinker telling you the kids a hot oh
wow yeah I don't know I don't ever [ __ ]
with Lima like that that's crazy
a street fight yeah that's a bad bad day
that's not what I'm thinking right now
[Music]
that's what kind of shoes those are I
like them you would um I'm a little old
but I like them do you have to dress
like you're 55 you're all
old cuz you think you're old bro old
here be listen guys these are your old
years now who'd sneaks Ralph Lauren Sox
nope these are also those are awesome
time at at shirt drives me the shirt is
not it's tag it's a beautiful blue dude
no girls gonna look at go I want to suck
his day it's a blue shirt dude I'm a
good-looking I'm a good look like you
just got off who makes those [ __ ]
shoes bro Gatsby I mean it could be
Gucci it could be dude you're on fire
today you really are in forward to it
yeah what they don't like that bro you
know what they say don't [ __ ] stress
yeah Oh [ __ ] stretch so you know ours
you're a big poster like acclimate I
stretch and I [ __ ] when I stretch I when
I stretch I try to kill myself with the
stretch I try to [ __ ] murder myself I
try to [ __ ] so hard and that I just
go and then someone finds me and they're
like you is stretching what do you think
of you when you wake up in the morning
what do you usually think what goes on
in your head besides maybe nothing
clouds the coffee I want coffee
immediately you want coffee right away
immediately okay and then oh you must
have tried the big brown rose oh I
haven't and thanks bro oh dude where is
it I'll try it now I'll just [ __ ]
straight up eat the beans I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah where is that big brown it
sells out boys tonight god I could get
you some okay well I know a guy and that
guy is you and you give me one and I'll
drink it okay there you go
what dude I'll make my own coffee bro
I'll go get no you go to [ __ ] I can't
believe you go to [ __ ] pee Bay Peter
its coffee bean food you don't know
anything about food you are for that
[ __ ] dude what do you have what do I
want to be a boring [ __ ] that's like
money you gotta go to this restaurant
dude [ __ ] those kinds of guys you know
what [ __ ] the kinds of guys how about
the guys when you're like when you're
like on the road and they're like hey
you got to go to this place and you're
like I'll do my show Thanks oh let me go
out of my way to a [ __ ] but it's good
food some [ __ ] some Oh cows let's
say
hey dude I live in Los Angeles I can get
all the good food dude I'm gonna be at
all yo I'm in Cleveland smokehouse in
Columbus I help you out
put your face under my balls bro let me
rub my taint on your [ __ ] eyes come
on who's mad dude don't be nice to me
bro be regular alright well what if I go
almost figured all that out to lunch
today bro you think I give a [ __ ] bro
I'm gonna faint
sitting down have you ever done that
what have you what did you do last night
that you would say [ __ ] like Sean
Hannity do you seat you up in the night
every night he it's like a stack of
packing no dude that's off this off
penis Bala see dude I [ __ ] eat real
good like what chocolate chip pancakes
no man I you know [ __ ] protein ding
ding yeah
are you protein ping ping and I [ __ ]
you know I make sure I eat the leafy
greens and I thought the PATA
and your neck is jutting your heads
jutting it forward your isn't in line
with your shoulder you look tired
yeah I'm tired as [ __ ] why man it's
really new breakfast we gotta eat after
this hey what kind of [ __ ] cool hot
spot do you want to go dude how about
Brian when he [ __ ] post an Instagram
video of him and his friends in a dark
that's it I'm alone and I go like this
god [ __ ] did you got mad I did
it for the for Disney [ __ ] look at
your face Brian turn your eyes I got hey
listen guys this dude ain't maybe I'll
get my give me I'll get my eyes just
tucked up a little huh
it wasn't hurt it would kill you not
seeing all your eyes are gone sorry
my mother said do that thing time my
family your your eyes go you know what
it's last call right your I just saying
it's last to annoy what's falling is I
don't like this Chris Oh gotcha
pulling the blinds then I got a cooler
nights coming I might have to get my
eyes talk oh cool yeah you know what you
need to get you know you need to talk to
Clark
I mean what some fee you know some fee
those automatic blinds and you just get
a [ __ ] thing they come in and they
install the [ __ ] in your [ __ ] thing
and then you have a thing and every time
you start to look old you just go and it
goes and then you look a little bit
younger dude I'd like that that's some
some fish I do you look how seared
you're they do this you know it looks
like you're dead serious
trying to looks out here with a kids
book no no that's not a kids book that's
to come bro second grade and by the way
you guys like why the way dude you look
like a [ __ ] drama teacher right there
and it's pissing me off
well I am I could teach drama because I
know a lot about acting look at my
fingers they're I'm pinching it so you
see the whole book by the way they made
they said look pose something right now
selfie yeah what is it what do I have to
I I tagged something who's they did they
say you for it
first booked out first book Oregon magic
of storytelling I had to do it who did
they do it cool bro you're not saying
he's needed okay who at Disney and why I
don't know they were just there they had
a whole photo booth set up so I wouldn't
did it it was about it was about like
literacy in the inner city and all that
so then they had me do that do I bet
that made a difference that's a kid
looked out of it you know what I'm gonna
pick that whole guy he's really going to
do it it's not the same thanks Alfred
who [ __ ] cares you're complaining
about this [ __ ] a comedian says the
jokey look a meeting Oh Rita happy but I
did read eight years in power were mean
to people are really nice Irena I've
read everything by Tom house it goes you
are really nice post stuff like that man
yeah I love it
hashtag magic storytelling [ __ ] right
you know what though I'm all I'm so old
that they tend to be a little nicer to
me they're like half [ __ ] it isn't
matter really you ever looked at lately
oh it might be true though actually if
you think about it cuz once he's older
yeah why you know cuz like dude I still
get [ __ ] like I mean are you some young
I'm really young they're gonna be forty
scented relax in [ __ ] two years bro
well relax dude in two years around a
year in a year in some it's in a year
and [ __ ] two months yeah it's not weird
I'm gonna be 40 Wow
and you'll be 45 in three months time
flies I don't know yeah but I'll be
[ __ ] you're still a young kid you're
35 yeah yeah but that turns into [ __ ]
39 soon I know it does no trail of me
with you guys a lot of times oh I'm just
yeah in a wet you in a wheelchair in
five years I'm into longevity drugs
that's my new thing now oh cool cool do
you still have psoriasis no I don't oh
cool
well wonder what you're gonna get now
just trying some new [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll
put up in cinemate on and I give it I'll
take it I'll take it somebody goes like
this you know Brian I got this new I got
what is it - give it to me no don't be a
BA you go like this guy goes hey I got
this new and you up yep and the guy goes
plunk and your body goes one of those
rumors no [ __ ] whatever yes rice rice
tentacles are you you dude psoriasis
remember we were just talking about that
all right what happened with Brian the
guy that we were just talking to I don't
know you switched your body switch to
someone else that's the only thing that
makes sense
how did you get lost in one sentence man
you're gonna be a really bad father no
I'm not do it my kids are gonna be [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro they're gonna be like whatever
daddy we do not want to make a mistake
oh well yeah kids are I'm doing a map
helped me a memory it was a math problem
all right ready okay huh what's wrong
what's wrong I don't know why not what
is it four times a what four times a
well how many times well you know what
eight is yeah all right
what's that twice what's 8 twice you
can't eat candy for the rest of the
night and it's 3:00 and it's 3:00 p.m.
you can you for the rest of the night
think about it we're gonna yeah okay
good real
trust me or they'll get real hungry that
seems so harsh she'll be shredded not
gonna be a good day I'm gonna be a
[ __ ] great dad dude I can't wait to
[ __ ] you neck dad what are you
talking about bro say the thing about my
neck again dude say a gun dude what's up
with yo I'm just chillin man I don't
give a [ __ ] about this [ __ ] man
I'm so I'm so I'll dude he's doing man
they're good man we we know what's up
man I got I I'm just I'm just trying to
get to the point where everyone will
take care of me and my [ __ ] log cabin
dude with the high grass dude I can't
wait to go I want to build it you want
to go out there are you talking I have a
cult I have a call this
I'm streamlining everything into this
[ __ ] cult people are starting to
we're all new to my shows all blue
that's what I want why why do you want
the mini you gotta pick our color dude
you got to pick a [ __ ] color for them
to come but does it depend on the city
you pick the color
no don't you believe in the individual
you're trying to all the individual or
all the individual but what I mean we
are all cuz they're all five you seen
Voltron dude I'll form the head and
everyone else you pick a [ __ ] limb
because we are getting in a high grass
and we are going to build a log cabin
dude we were going to build a long cab
what's the point of this cult [ __ ]
and sucking and sharing ideas oh my god
keep trying baby [ __ ] and sucking
yeah bro yeah alright so I just feel
like there's nothing positive about this
what an only positive sharing ideas
about what about whatever the [ __ ] you
want do but not dumb [ __ ] like what
would be dumb [ __ ] Christ you want to
talk about fo you want to get like too
far into sports and so annoying
are the things people are not allowed to
talk about in your community it's like
an unspoken rule like you don't really
talk about that dumb [ __ ] so what if I
show up in it in my own outfit yeah
that's okay alright what if I show up my
get to the upper tier you know there's
an upper tier well dude you die you want
to be taken care of right you don't want
to [ __ ] go to the very depths of hell
all right I guess not yeah you don't so
you wear the blue you have bro I did so
slouch down disrespectful what are you
doing here my core dude is not a place
to work I don't normally [ __ ] go this
long without taking care of my [ __ ]
core okay well so I'm just gonna chill
for a little bit this is dude by the way
all right you know I get it
yeah but it's so annoying how many
[ __ ] views I get on your [ __ ]
podcast it's not bad flexibility my legs
won't go stir yeah I have really good
flexibility you can do that and I can
can you could you ever have yeah yeah so
it's okay you can do physically I can do
better do it now now right so you're
better at [ __ ] yourself got you that
you're better at [ __ ] yourself
you're better at lose your hair is not
I'm worried because the Samson effect
will take full full bore which is well
if you lose your hair we all know what
happened to the old career I'm gonna
shave desert trust me man I want to
[ __ ] shave my head yeah but then nah
I'm gonna get beefy enough to where I'm
gonna shave my head and it's gonna be a
whole different ballgame my baby oh oh
yeah you want to talk about traps dude
I'm gonna do steroids I don't give a
[ __ ] I will do if I lose my hair I'll do
steroids and I'll make a gap in my teeth
I don't give a [ __ ] oh oh you think oh
oh hai steroids nice to meet you you
think you're going to space my teeth out
no no no no no no no no no no no I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] penny and I'm gonna
[ __ ] hammer that [ __ ] up in there
I'll beat you to it you [ __ ] nice guy
I'll beat you to it you nice guy on
steroids NAB not so aggressive I went
from me it's super you're not losing
right a little bit but everyone does a
little bit when you get older
don't get on the old apish because you
gotta salvage it before it yeah he's
really getting thin I'm sorry I am NOT
your neck is getting it's losing its
character its losing its shape my whole
family has hair man they never lost
their hair I'm gonna pop says get here
yeah yeah but you're not my dad's went
back a little bit but it's all [ __ ]
your character so the middle doesn't
yeah I'm good I'm good it'll goes that
you you know goes huh mine's not give
more hair than you had yeah I take
propecia okay well you're on it right
now B yeah that him stuff I actually
think I have more hair than I did about
[ __ ] two years ago because I've been
wrong I've been taking boobies yeah why
wouldn't you yeah I mean just a case you
know dude I can't because I'm worried
it's gonna run into my breaths
well yeah you don't have much to worry
about do you yeah but it's weird you're
starting your [ __ ] forehead I know so
think if I took propecia just go you
have this straighten your hair isn't
your hair naturally get super curly
found a product in it gets well I hit
that jew-fro you could shave your hair
to you got with a cool usually my head I
did it when I was fighting yeah I saw
okay well I don't any trouble dude you
did yeah dude shave yours be I used to
yeah you would you have a good head I
used to shave my head all the time
should you can't do it honey pictures
online I know that's what I'm saying why
not do it I will
now that she knows not probably not
gonna come back yeah it is yeah I know
it's a hit huh that's annoying
I don't you said it only last for Chris
remember yeah I am cute kid right there
oh wow the hair wasn't great there how
old were you there I was 40
the hair was starting to believe that
they're the hard way that in the corner
[ __ ] yeah but it was always it's always
like that
no but you you've probably always had
hair like that yes like you probably
always had that yeah but I had a hair
transplant but it didn't really take
yeah but when you were young like like
how old is he there oh cool Groupon for
stand up group on it stand of life far
I've got you one six look at look at
Sasa's calf look at my face
that's amazing she they scroll up how
about the picture of me and Brian okay
he was growing up when I got could I
look any gayer that third picture in I
mean I will suck out there bro yeah yeah
well Brian you were way bigger oh oh
this sweater hmm I am big there though I
was lifting and eating a lot
okay so then not the sweater yeah
because and this one I'm like kid now
all right well we look like two gay men
there yeah we really do that's fantastic
yeah yeah all right should we do some
current events sure we oh we're all
getting older we're all changing aren't
we guys yeah that's what happens I'm
getting older so have you guys heard of
the Colorado man that killed a young
cougar no juvenile cougar didn't yeah
this guy was on a hiking trip or no
trail within a hiking area but he was
running which made the Cougar instinct
really want to chase the guy down and
when he turned around he saw the Cougar
he didn't specify how he choked out the
Cougar but he choked it out and killed
it so what made the Cougar wanna get him
he's food he was running food he's
running gun yeah yeah Wow and he killed
the Cougar by [ __ ] vacating it with a
flick a ting it knows fingers in the
nose no choke exactly I always want to
do that dude to a stupid animal like
sometimes with my dad's dog come Raj you
know just be sitting I'll put my two
fingers just over the snout and see how
long before they move I'm like I could
kill this thing so he took these fingers
that's crazy like with your little dog
that you're like Ted Bundy but yeah dude
you look like you don't really why is
everybody keep saying so many people tag
me like dude do tell Kristen like Deanna
you know I now said I know people 70,000
people say this you don't actually look
like him there's no one picture where
you do yeah never say my eyes and face
but guess what we did you if I ma'am I
attacked you
no I probably thought that was in
Colorado where they killed that mountain
line right mm-hmm that way yeah that one
on the left it small around that one
right there I post by the way seven
years ago up there nothing then next to
it were you're waving yeah yeah I don't
look at that oh wow you post that a long
time ago years ago I mean yeah that's
why uh God just don't like that much
alike yeah not really why did you summon
oh your face like say because he's not
doing that I I thought that that's what
he was doing well yours is way
exaggerated well you know common in
don't Iike my Ted Bundy face yeah if you
all look like a manaro I mean I kind of
don't you know I heard I heard the
movies amazing it is really good
it's a miniseries yet oh oh oh I found
boring do you see the whole thing
watched three and the last episode is
[ __ ] really so boring I liked it a
lot the last Wow the last one is good
one I just because it's like it go it
goes into him getting the chair and like
he's talking about it and he finally
confesses to all the [ __ ]
oh did he confess of it yeah God The
Beginner's kind of like all hypothetical
and yeah would you let me know how you
kill these integers I still liked it but
but the last episode is amazing yeah
yeah it's right here
so it is Lunar New Year and there's a
video that was released of two
grandparents in China while the
fireworks are going off
it's year of the
well that's because they can't hear it
it's [ __ ] out they have no idea
what's going on this is how there is
there so what the [ __ ] hey that's
dangerous
well they've also seen 150 years that's
sure they don't care wow that's [ __ ]
fifty years Jesus
yeah I think the hardest thing about
getting older is not being over
everything
no okay you know William F Buckley said
when he's 85 they go what do you feel
like as you know I think in some ways my
worst enemy are young doctors with good
medicine what do you mean he's get tired
of life they keep you alive for a long
time whoa
that's [ __ ] dark dude yeah yeah well
she has to go see I don't like what guys
say stuff so Hawaii is trying to make a
law towards banning cigarettes within
the next five years I disagree with it I
don't like any law that bans [ __ ] like
cigarettes and also they except unless
you're a hundred years old right like
yeah that's a that's not it that's not
actually a ban let them do what the [ __ ]
they want to do exactly it's country you
love sewing suits like I don't give a
[ __ ] if I die this is government trying
to legislate good health
well unless they're unless they're
trying to I mean in public I understand
you know public make sense yeah but how
do we how does it work out with weed
when you outlawed that how'd that work
out I mean you know yeah yeah good point
Prime you can't you can't make things
illegal though yeah you can cuz murder
and rape okay well I'm just I'm saying
smoking cigarettes like but just said
you about me really you to let people
there I think murder you you were born
the booze was illegal that was in the
[ __ ] twenties during Prohibition they
called you the Prohibition baby huh
Brian they Ted had followed dance
ya know was born in 1921 no CI yet so a
student came home to our apartment in
North Carolina and she thought that her
a permanent was haunted because
there are some weird things happening
one day she came home heard something in
her closet she said hello
and a man replied oh hey it's just me
and she found that there was a man
living in her apartment for the past
couple days and he was dressed in her
clothes in the closet mm-hmm damn he
seemed stable yeah oh dear shiny is he
losing it there
he's definitely losing it oh my word
he's not well is here's a combination of
both your guys you know I used to think
that [ __ ] was crazy now I just think
it's sad I mean it's not you know I mean
me too well cuz I think he's not in his
faculties however it's sad unless it's
your house with kids and then you're
gonna have to sad or not you know
there's there's there people have a
fetish and that fetish is to break into
houses and jerk off in their house and
smell pennies in their in their closets
just to jerk off somewhere that nobody
else has and leave your mark nope sorry
been there done that bro just someone
else's house yeah but also dude that was
way too specific to think that you
haven't done it now you've done it no no
man I'm hey what are you doing and do it
I start to [ __ ] see my future and I
got to put my sunglasses on what's your
future look like bright don't do that
laughs it's disrespectful it's also
super man you got to stop with that I
don't like the way you're sitting
hey do you guys ever think about
bringing back the 10 minute podcast was
a so you were talking about rethought
about it thought about it we'd do it
differently though when we what would
you do well we make Brian [ __ ] take
some comedy classes so he wouldn't
interrupt he wouldn't be [ __ ] big
killer Jones like he always is dude
Chris Lee and I'll be [ __ ] knee-deep
in a hilarious bit and Brian I'll be
like do you guys want tacos and [ __ ] it
all up
come a screeching halt Callen over your
hot Kris don't say screeching oh yeah
you're like a [ __ ] what's the
opposite of a juggernaut I don't know
like a table man evil dude table that
doesn't go anywhere for your even look
at your own table that doesn't go
anywhere for years that a family doesn't
even use they just put stuff on dude
your vials that's what you are dude and
they are they eatin for the TV and all
that [ __ ] and they never use that that
dining room table man that so your mouth
is too wet [ __ ] dining room table
Khalid on it you're lit your mouth gets
all wet when you get back but it gets
[ __ ] wet my mouth is like a [ __ ]
dude it's so great do when you go to
kiss a girl what do you would you ever
say any before you do it like yep when
you win your first time you gonna kiss a
girl Yeah right
mm and you're about to go in yep what
are you so so you're the end of the date
yup in a great time yeah and she wants
you to kiss her you maybe she doesn't
you don't know yep what do you do I go
like this I'm a Republican
why do you say that you might be able to
throw her off
I'm not even a Republican right I just
go I'm a Republican that's how you kiss
dude yup dude that's not good meat but
you're making your lips all puckered up
I know you're open they go Republican
and then I go and then I meet their lips
like that and then I use my lips too all
in their lips like that and then I stick
that's how I do it and then that comes a
[ __ ] Republican and I'm not even a
republican but I make girls Republicans
do now when you when you go downtown
yeah do you ever do that are you afraid
of you talking about a sideways burger
no that bleeds don't tell me you say
that to her
I say hey man there's no please don't
say hey come on be romantic in your
voice he would say I say hey baby yeah
make your burger sideways yeah what does
that mean make your burger sideways cuz
if they're like this they're chillin but
then they go like this what [ __ ] meat
then I meet the [ __ ] lifted the thing
Oh same thing better get inside actually
have sex yeah and do it uh-huh
what do you say that well what's her
name Mandy Mandy now let's say her name
is Penelope Penelope
okay so first time having sex I'm doing
it right before I haven't put it in
there yet no but I don't say much I just
like kiss and I make it nice and I
[ __ ] you know I make sure to like
look at him and use a lot of eye contact
and yeah and then right before I climax
what's her name Penelope okay I go like
this right before I climax I go like
this Oh Penelope I'm so cool
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right cool
have you ever had a girl say something
before she goes she has her thing um I
had a girl say I'm gonna go oh no really
yeah I'm gonna go you ready yeah yeah
imma go said I'm gonna go before she had
a no really yeah
not like oh I'm gonna go like I'm
getting out of here now so season two
you [ __ ] give me like [ __ ] just [ __ ]
yeah so so that's doesn't seem antic no
it's this [ __ ] dude
Oh Penelope I'm so cool oh and they're
like wait wait do you not think I'm cool
I figured out how to make it work oh
damn it is you guys get this right here
oh person Oh Mike no that's not a
drawing no that's actually that's not
like Ken doll no sella M&M Ken doll Joe
he stole someone's wallet and then he
was at a bar and then I guess they have
those things were in the chip and the
car that shows that it's stolen so I
found out that it was stolen call the
cops and he was pretending to be someone
else but they didn't show the other
person but apparently he doesn't he's
not like that guy at all be a [ __ ] Ken
doll he looks fake his [ __ ] man that's
his face done when he's old my yeah he's
got really good eyebrows though yeah oh
yeah they look natural it's Q [ __ ] Brian
huh why no I thought you dude why is he
look like he looks like a [ __ ] well
he's got I throw it guess who's got
makeup on
he painted his eyebrows on Duracell
battery guys remember those guys murder
commercial where they're just like and
they had the Duracell in the back oh you
know what you remember next all right
yeah the question when guys like that
and he stole a wallet and he's 20 right
he's on the Internet is he done for life
can he ever get a job even though he'll
be fine
he will yeah people will forget his face
well shave when they do a background
check his name will come up yeah that
that is true man I was reading this so
what happened thing about him soups I
was reading but this thing about this
Jon Ronson book and he was saying how
[ __ ] you know was all about porn and
this guy had like a legit job in as a
nurse and he was like helping people and
they found out because of the internet
when it when it came out I fire and and
they were like you got to get fired any
was like a [ __ ] normal have you think
that that it was the governor in
Virginia in high school he did a KKK
thing in chocolate face thing and then
the trying to give him resign now yeah
this was in high school also back then
in that from what I've heard different
clients just from a black every law
professor who was talking about how I
think in that part of the South
blackface was like a Halloween people
dressing like Jackson 5 yeah
immersed soul man so man and that to
remember soul man an 84 good one right
so so so man was waiting in line was it
was in blackface playing a black guy
yeah crazy okay so you don't saying but
the whole country went to see that movie
I think it did pretty well yeah funny
how things change so we you know what's
into is he did have a KKK guy next to
him so what was that about I don't know
was he KKK know what it is what about
not Virginia governor well dak Shepherd
made a good point he was saying with the
the culture in now on this podcast
armchair expert he said what we're doing
now we're we're like someone I make a
mistake or someone does something and we
just [ __ ] put them into exile like
get the [ __ ] out of you guys right dude
if you look at over the time of some
great artists like freaking John Lennon
or anybody put POSCO they have their
[ __ ] man like they made some
imagine if so there's someone who's just
as good as Picasso just gives John
Lennon today who are making mistakes
won't go nope you're done no chances so
we're never gonna enjoy their talents
well so shut those people if I give you
some perspective so Amazing Grace which
is sung by in a lot of black churches
it's it's oh so it was written by a
slave holder he owned slaves he had a
conversion when he had his conversion
and realized it was wrong he wrote the
song amazing grace
the reason Amazing Grace such a powerful
songs it's about redemption about change
about how your soul and heart can change
so that the bigger question is that guy
was in high school right this is a grown
man was everybody here different in high
school what the [ __ ] we talking about
here I'm saying say yeah we all changed
I remember when I when I didn't know
anything but I didn't know a lot of gay
people and I had an argument with him I
was 20 I don't I remember this girl 21
watch her both her parents were raised
by it where she was raised by gay I
denote by a gay couple or both the
parents turned out to be gay
I was making an argument that I thought
gay couples shouldn't be able to allowed
to adopt children because I didn't know
I didn't know gay I didn't know gay
people I didn't know I just thought it
didn't make sense I was like that seems
dangerous or bad cuz that was hell I
wasn't taught any differently and then
guess what you change you grow older and
you meet gay people than you
you know kids that are raised by gay
people and you go wait that kids fine
and then somebody goes would rather be
them an orphanage foster care or two
loving people and you know yeah that
makes sense
so guess what I [ __ ] changed my mind
yeah well you were a child yeah I know
but you but I was 20 of 21 what I'm
saying is that we [ __ ] change scroll
into that sense that's him and Chuck
Bass in a KKK member right yeah it's
weird
he was a kid that wasn't he wasn't you
say That's not me
19 years old yeah tell what yelling is
also at 19 should he not be allowed to
be governor not change if he's I do that
I know of course you can chance poor
yeah yeah I mean a [ __ ] will have all
of us never made a mistake or done
something that would be considered
offensive he probably might not even
thought it was offensive back then I
don't know I mean I don't know
oh you know yeah I understand but I'll
let you governor races though what about
what Liam Neeson said you see that that
was fun oh yeah tense but it was a
moment when he was out of his mind
somebody who do black guys right was
raped so you know and he admitted it
does that mean he's racist no does that
means a bad guy no it means that he was
injured watch your P's and Q's everybody
has moments where they say [ __ ] and do
things that are not but now when you do
it you better come correct and you lose
some jobs over specially wooden
entertainment it's a hard that's a hard
thing I understand people going wait a
minute you got a [ __ ] KKK guy there
and you're in blackface I get that you
have to explain that let's talk top you
see the KKK or the blackface they don't
know apparently oh I would be more I
would be more forgiving of the blackface
than the guy drew I would never have
dressed up in a KKK thing and I think
I'm so scared of him my dad had dev
talks to me that but I just never
thought that I would have thought that
was very offensive him I didn't need
somebody tell me that back then yeah I
mean you know I mean like what do you
mean what if a black guy sees me what if
a black dude sees me as it's a Kate
what's funny about that I'm messing up
in a feud and how about that black guy
last night calling you out with your
scarf from Delta here that was the best
I'm standing next just I don't know I'm
wearing scarf and he goes he goes is
that he and I never wear scarves and you
guys are already giving me [ __ ] about
his company goes you get that off of
American Airlines and I go what and he
goes did you take that Jew was you given
that by the airline I go no and he goes
he takes it off me he goes yeah you were
and it says clouds calm why did you get
a scarf for him I don't know why my
mother's or something why would they
give scarfs it was my first class or
something dude we dude dude I had a
buddy and he had these sunglasses that
he would always wear and we were walking
one day down the street
it was [ __ ] 20-something do it a
respectful during the story and and I'm
he's talking and I'm looking at him I
was walking next to each other and I say
do your [ __ ] sunglasses say ABC
sports and he says what and I was like
does it say ABC sports on this like a
real small thing and he was like no and
I was like
yeah it does and he was like the [ __ ]
are you talking about and he was like oh
my god he was wearing these [ __ ] cool
dope song as I said ABC spoken for free
I don't know dude but we laughed so hard
man and I never talked to him again
because I got the best foot friend s
fool no Chris no that's not no it's not
very less you guys got this right here
this is supposed to be one of the
coolest punters I don't know any guy
that does that actual post that's a
punter punter for Miami Hurricanes Jesus
Christ he's jacked for absolute that is
the putter six for 10 15 pounds holy
[ __ ] Wow even Sports Illustrated picked
it up like this is the coolest punter
ever how funny and he has a video just a
little kicking video right there well I
mean I don't know much about these kicks
if it's good or not
dude well he's playing for Miami it's
pretty [ __ ] good the only thing is
ahold 24 my ass he's 24 playing for
Miami they say they're usually younger
than that like 19 years sink in redshirt
door you could he could he could have
not went to college right my main
University you might he could wait for
them he can throw in soccer and there
was like on into college incoming Haley
so you could do that in another or you
could be 30 and yo yeah my quarterback
Joel clout was like 27 and I was night
what the advantages ridiculous so they
literally are just there's no aids on it
they literally are just picking this up
cuz he has tattoos goodies because he
looks different for that yeah yeah very
strange yeah I also didn't know that's a
very second tattoos
24 years old he looks older to follow
older so then when he hits pro if he
everyone probably might be [ __ ] 29 or
something it's crazy it's really weird
I had no idea senior I had no idea I
thought that was your eligibility in
that sport starts when you entered yeah
you could be an old ticker problem you
say you couldn't play football all that
time and then come back to college
obviously no he like you'd have to do it
like did a lot of guys get drafted in
Major League Baseball
all right and they go play big league
baseball then come back and go college
football you can do that right you can't
do the same support in turn bro mm-hmm
Wow if your eligibility never started
the clock starts once you enroll in
school Wow whether no matter what you do
outside of it hmm Chris Weinke was
always like what does he get all right
this year so shaggy
you know from scooby-doo he like there's
memes going around in the gaming world
that he was supposed to be a playable
character in the new Mortal Kombat
Mortal Kombat 11 no sense but I have no
idea what he gained so much steam that
there was like three hundred forty
thousand some signatures to make it
happen but yeah three forty thousand
signatures Chris you play video games I
don't
so they made him no it was jus is
rumored people got people started loving
it but then it turns out it's not gonna
be a character had been cool I I don't I
I wish I played video games they look
fun and but every time I get a
controller I'm like well it's like what
the [ __ ] going on I don't want to have
to be born first in the video game you
know what I mean you're like gotta learn
how to walk and stuff and they're like
uh this is how you I don't to learn the
[ __ ] I just want to [ __ ] jump and
[ __ ] shoot would it be face save save
I said what would you do what did they
say that what do you do during the day
would it be safe to say that you could
always just go nothing no I work out I
[ __ ] everyday it's kind of nothing to
though I did pretty much every day
almost I'm on the road a lot
getting bags you know how that goes yeah
yeah yeah you got many bad during the
day nothing huh you know my father met a
Duke like a Duke from England okay they
were having dinner and my father said
what do you do and he goes nothing
nothing I just left it that way my
father was at this business dinner and
this guy was a Duke he was yeah you know
what royalty and my father said what are
you doing he said nothing nothing oh
yeah my father was like okay how do you
follow up with just a [ __ ] aristocrat
I'm nothing nothing oh my god dude that
guy is my hero
they case I know my dad was like I've
never met anybody just does nothing
anybody yeah Wow the guy's awesome
nothing nothing at all what else you do
that's cool just one more he was a lord
this guy so he was trying to rob a
Popeye's Chicken in New Orleans and if
the register wouldn't open so he just
took Fried Chicken and left oh wow he's
saying I'm feeling uh chicken meows cuz
I mean he couldn't get to the cash so
might as well get something I guess ones
last time you guys had Popeyes Chicken
ah it's really good it's all right it's
great I bet maybe he was just trying so
hard for so long that eventually he got
you worked up I'm gonna get something
you know what [ __ ] this money I give me
the chicken mmm maybe well good luck to
that man I feel like you everyone's
Energy's gone down
Stu should we just show you lights off
and lay down let's go that's great sushi
dude I'm so hungry we're gonna go eat
and Brian's gonna be sushi now you have
dude sugar fish on you you know what
your face is awesome for me it really is
he's one right up the street longer well
better share fish all right that's good
let's shut the lights off take a nap
sounds like eBay our lives are good
let's do a quick song and we'll all sing
a song I'll start and you add it you add
to it and you add to it ready editor
okay can I get a beat though can you
give me a sort of better let's just kind
of do something Leary on your pillow
nice let's shut the lights down on our
lives sometimes you gotta take a break
you gotta decide that the rat race is
just too long a chain cut the lights
let's go nuts too but I'm in the middle
it's gonna feel so good
I don't know if that's a good idea maybe
we should just live our lives the way
we've been living them and not going
having sex with the lights out and never
ever listen to Brian that's not true
because if we are gonna shut the lights
out and go nuts to butts no let's make
sure we wrap it up and I don't look each
other in the eyes that's definite we're
gonna bust now let's run a train on jizz
in the dark busting nuts in the bus
tonight aren't you in respective houses
and not with each other what did you say
what are you saying busting nuts at our
own respective houses not near each
other I'll do mine in Beverly Hills and
you do yours in wherever you live I'm
not but I don't know where it could be
or it could be why don't really know
about it because I don't want to bring
up the hard times who knows what's going
on with your situation I don't know what
the show knows
I'm not sure what you're talking about
but be quiet anyway yeah I got it this
song was all made up and it's not ring
yeah this is the five kids were out
[Laughter]